dude that was in an Alleyway and he was
uh it was the sun was going down so he's
praying oh I saw that wherever you are
you got to PR I saw it in New York City
and he he was
like just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in if you
want to look sharp like me all your CED
clothing as you can see c.com all day
every day Zan like the pocket Zan you
can put a lot of stuff in here no no
labels nothing that's how we roll it
yeah cuz you have no um
I just got I just got some dendra for my
glasses I'm just going to clean that
please do that Zan what's your take on
Joe
Rogan I think I don't know what to make
out of him like I'll be honest with you
I think Joe Rogan has given a platform
to a lot of um Rogan a lot of
nonmainstream people that have shared
their ideas because let's face it I mean
when it comes to mainstream television
you only fed the same thing again and
again he provided an alternative and
because of that because of his genuine
inquisitive nature he's not only risen
to prominence but he's helped
significantly Donald Trump who thanked
him in his uh winning speech and he
mentioned a bunch of people and then he
said something along the lines of uh
then the ultimate Joe Rogan or whatever
so Trump biged up Joe Rogan well Joe
Rogan in this clip is biging up Muslims
should we find out way really come on
yeah and he's actually saw seen two of
them with his guest or about how musl
even though even though some people say
oh why do we care about what people say
about Islam and this and that however
when we're living in a society that is
very celebrity
oriented it does have an impact on
people's opinions and does you know
shape people's mind and it's strategic
why not here we go this what he had to
say my friend that did it he's now out
of it um of the priesthood or the gay he
left the priesthood he's still gay still
Queer as they
come uh but he left the priesthood which
was weird cuz we were like whoa is he
coming out is he this and he left and
now um uh he just said they were
changing too many things like the
literal religion messed him up to get
him out really interesting were they
changing the Catholic church I and my
mom please she she doesn't know how to
listen to podcast anyway the Catholic
Church uh changes on a dime like even
something lent right now we're in Lent
right right there was so many rules that
my mom had that we don't have like my
generation didn't have and now
it's a whole another like lent is not
now I'm looking at kids like what you
could do that it's lent you're not
allowed to you have to do this this and
this but they've changed they just
changed so that they can recruit that's
why the Muslims are going to win they
don't give a joins that's Ramadan is you
got a month and nobody's eating all day
long no water no food we were uh in
downtown the other day driving downtown
LA and there's an alleyway and this dude
was in the alleyway in La as no in
Austin did I say la did I I'm sorry in
Austin downtown Austin and uh there was
this dude that was in an Alleyway and he
was uh it was the sun was going down so
he was
praying I saw that wherever you are you
got to pray I saw it in New York City
and he he was like and it's so hard to
find a space in New York city so I I was
like wow that is impressive exactly he
was behind like a pillar that like went
into there was a little bit of room to
go into these offices and he was
literally just behind the pillar just
doing that and I was like wow that is
right in Time Square wow this is in
Toronto so this is a protest for
something oh there it is yeah Toronto
but it's still it's still it's a protest
okay I even if it's a protest you get
that many people that are doing that
there's not another religion that would
do that that would do that they are so
much more devout in their belief than CU
they're praying like the Catholics would
just wait wave a cross in your face they
do half a lot of
people the Muslims are out there in the
street on their knees your traffic we're
we're praying your traffic which is this
is that's a different thing Toronto it's
busy Joe Rogan seeing a man praying in
Alleyway and this is why it's really
important cuz sometimes when I used to
like do Uber when I used to drive I had
to pray outside bro like cuz masjids are
closed do you get it and a lot of people
comment say why do you go to the Masjid
there's very reasons I've got the kids
in the car I can't take the whole kids
you get what I'm trying to say so it's
like some I'll pray in the back and I'll
be honest with you I've had like I've
had obviously you get people like get
Muslims come and try to put carp in
front of you or say maral or whatever
that matter but what you need to bear in
mind is how are non-muslims perceiving
you now when I pray outside a lot of
people sometimes I would ask certain
brothers that maybe newly practicing Etc
and they're like praying and they they
they find it a little bit embarrassing
and I'm like like I don't say nothing
but I'm like BR why should I be
embarrassed what what am I doing
embarrassing people are having sex
in public some Madness that escalated
very quickly fastly yeah actually do and
it's one of the signs of the hour
actually one of the signs of the hour is
that two people having intimacy on the
road and the best amongst them will say
go behind the wall so it says what if
they have no shame doing that which an
action that's going to testify against
him why am I going to be shy and
embarrassed and the same thing we have
when it comes to enjoying evil you see a
brother or with a girl or whatever
kissing what a har relationship yeah you
had to I'm so sorry yeah and people come
and say oh advise them bro I feel
embarrassed they don't feel embarrassed
doing that in public you feel
embarrassed advising them our would Dean
that's what Allah says let their rise
amongst you a group of people who were
enjoy enough forb evil so when it comes
to this it shows you that's why there
was a guy in in the back of a cab and he
said my cab driver is just going to now
to pray yeah and I'll be honest with you
when I was a c driver there's one moment
I had to do that there was a two guy I
think one guy and his girlfriend they
were kind of Tipsy I said guys I
genuinely have to pray so I can either
you can either cancel this ride they
said no we wait for you bro you know
happen you won't believe this did they
accept Islam no bro I went out to pray
bro the woman came not right next to me
besides me just not praying with me bro
she started liter I finished I didn't
know when I looked there I could hear
something and she was like Yeah I wanted
to pray with she was doing something I
don't know what she was doing yeah but
the thing is it just shows you that this
has value and people judge by your
actions and sometimes when you're just
um you know time for Salah comes
obviously your primary intention is to
pray to Allah however when you put that
a mat down you think oh you know who's
watching me and this and that you can
either see it in a negative way like
who's watching me or what are they
thinking or you could think it in a
positive da Centric sort of way that if
someone is watching this is going to
appeal to the F this is going to appeal
to the Natural disposition that this
this there's something familiar about
this there's something safe about this
there's something for you know something
unique and special about this because
this is the way that the prophets are
you look in the old and the New
Testament you know this is how the
prophets prayed we know in the garden of
get geami Jesus put his head on the
floor and bowed down some say that he
was bowing down to himself because of
course he's God and you know all of that
sort of stuff however sticking with the
point you don't know who you're giving
da to you don't know the impact of that
Salah like ibraim Alam when he was in
the desert and he made the call they
were like it's up to Allah to take his
call and it everybody and look worldwide
people to and
visina there's not a moment that
somebody is not doing ta there's not a
moment exactly and not only that you
know when you in Salah cuz if you see it
what was J connecting what was it doing
a correlation with the prayer he was
saying and they're going to win because
it shows dedication that's why when he
talked about said the guy only knows
Allah and wrestling and Allah something
like that yeah he connected it directly
to to um ESS so you can see he's like
these people are going to win why
because they're not degenerate do you
get it we have a purpose we have a focus
and that's one thing nobody can take
away from us and not only that when
you're praying you're showing Liberation
you're showing true Liberation why cuz
you are connecting yourself to the
Creator not caring about the creation
because for one to go and pray you're
basically saying I don't care what you
think of me I don't care if you laugh at
me I don't care about the D I'm here
with my Lord that is like a true power
empowerment bro when you look at someone
and be like and let me be honest like
sometimes when I was not a Muslim and I
would see women who wear the hijab in I
was like like I salute that bro I salute
that because what of the degeneracy
that's going on the fact that you're
choosing to do the opposite I I don't
think I ever came across muslims praying
on the street I don't remember that yeah
but I had some friends here and their
pre but I'm sure you had friends yeah
whoa come on before you I had good
friends oh I'm glad that changed there's
another important point which is that
the rules and the discipline is what
non-muslims especially in this day of
postmodernism where it's all about
subject ity you have these people that
are sticking true to their beliefs their
ideals such that they are able to stay
true to themselves this is something
that people without rules really value
and it's so ironic that you have certain
Muslims that are on the border of kufur
and saying no there's too many rules and
we feel like this or the non-muslims
that come to Islam they love the fact
that there's so many rules that there's
order there is discipline look at
Judaism you think Islam's got rules and
regulations brother I know some Jewish
people I went to the synagogue the rules
they have bro W bro you will thank Allah
for Islam bro you think that we have
rules bro we are we got it easy mate bro
there's some regular they have to follow
with water next to the bedroom the bed
bro I was bro that is crazy but even
like in New York City there's like this
thin line that goes all the way around
they're trying to do one in Liverpool
now Manchester they're trying to kind of
find ways around in which they can kind
of maneuver around their yeah religious
responsibilities but this it comes back
to this point the discipline but why are
they doing that because their religion
is so hard so they have no choice but to
find ways of getting out out of it but
with us and they they did that to their
self because we know in the Quran Allah
tells us that they made a which cow what
color this that sorry you know but
that's why Islam is a balanced you know
religion but something that tells us how
to go to the toilet somebody that tells
us how to you know what to put in our
Wills something that is there how to
deal with your marital issue
everything bus everything it's a way of
life but yeah me yeah that's it guys I
mean is
that don't forget to subscribe to SM to
I mean smile to Jen come on and don't
forget to unsubscribe to Ali da nice
byebye Zan bye I'm going to get you some
cind clothing
[Laughter]
yeah yeah Al can you take that b what
said no thanks ourselves